The Narrative that is being put on what
looks to be a very horrific incident is
inflammatory it's coming from the
president on down that we are living
through an epidemic of racially biased
police killings of black men that is
completely false President Biden just
said oh that the criminal justice system
denies equal treatment to blacks he
should know better study after study
coming out of Harvard out of Michigan
State University out of the left-wing
Center for policing Equity shows that
there is no bias in fatal police
shooting she blames diversity training
and implicit bias training that we need
more use of force training that's what
we need for police
and then she makes the Bold claim that
there was no racial bias there is no
racial bias in police and fatal police
shootings and this just flies in the
face
of what we know